I wonder because obviously it's quite
intimate isn't it from the very
beginning for you as an actress how do
you approach that and and what
difference does it make when you've
worked with the actor for the very first
time as well were you kind of doing that
well in this case it was perfect that we
had not met because the characters
haven't met and very quickly they're
very intimate so I think we both had
probably were seasoned enough actors to
use that to our advantage
don't tell me about the emotional and
physical demands of playing a role like
this well the physical demands were
plenty marca is a real-life guy there's
a short film called breathing lessons by
Jessica you and in that film I was able
to to hear the sound of his voice and to
actually see you know the the challenge
ahead of me as far as trying to
replicate his body his polio ravaged
frame I wanted to capture the mark that
I saw in that film as as much as I could
so that people who survived him would be
able to recognize something of their
friend or relative and what I'd done
what points in the story did you feel
you've really sort of understood what it
was that he was going through well I
know that between takes sometimes I
would be lying on a gurney and various
crew members would lay props and and
coats and soda pops on top of me and I
thought I must be getting something
right at that point mark spoke of being
invisible to able-bodied people and in
those moments I felt like perhaps I was
stupid and this point intimate scenes
isn't it from there quite early on with
Helen Hunt how do you approach those as
an actor well we weren't looking for the
perfect fantasy we were looking for the
truth
love seems by nature are going to be
awkward unwieldy everyone on set is
going to be nervous gonna be unfamiliar
and the fact that Helen and I didn't
know each other well I think actually
worked in our favor
and the subsequent intimate scenes as we
got to know each other better and gained
comfort so were our characters so it was
a nice parallel
you